number two we have to be a United I
could say party but I want to say
movement because it's not about a party
right like I happen to have registered
as a republican in Florida but I don't
consider myself I certainly don't
consider myself like a standard
Republican or even a standard
conservative but a movement a wide
movement of all sorts of freedom-loving
people who can argue about driver's
licenses at the libertarian end and can
argue about uh same-sex marriage or
whatever else but all agree that we want
to live in America we believe in
individual rights we believe the
founding is good that's what we must do
and then from a party perspective you
have to support good candidates Blake
Masters it does look like he's going to
lose I don't think he's officially
conceded yet but it does look it's a
damn shame because he's a good man he is
a he has a bright future in front of him
for sure but it does look like he's
going to lose in Arizona uh he was on TV
talking about how the Republican machine
did not help him enough at best just
incompetent but you know what else is
incompetent Tucker The Establishment
right the people who control the purse
strings Senate leadership fund Mitch
McConnell McConnell decided to spend
millions of dollars attacking a fellow
Republican in Alaska instead of helping
me defeat Senator Mark Kelly had he
chosen to spend money in Arizona this
race would be over we'd be celebrating a
senate majority right now
so look I don't like to think it's all
about money but a lot of it is about
money and we need an apparatus let's say
again broadly on the right it's not
about purely Republican or something but
an apparatus that is focused and
efficient and all of those things that
is using money well
um I don't think we have that at the
moment and I think more and more people
are realizing that after this election